Yeah.
Hey, what's going on? Is Bill Burn?
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Monday morning podcast just before Friday.
And
[inaudible]
just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you
so you know your week's going.
Oh, it's Thursday. You know,
somebody gave me shit the other day.
Fucking talking about how, uh, you know,
I always say Thursday, it's payday.
I go, who couldn't fucking job?
Did you have, will you got by?
I always got paid on Friday. I always
get paid on Thursday. Whatever.
So you're getting your money today
or getting it tomorrow, right?
We all know you're going to be broke by
Tuesday. Right? Wednesday walking around,
you know with your brown bag,
you got to bring a fucking lunch
cause you got no money for fucking
to go out to the roach coach.
Yeah, you packed a lot.
Chatty on funny, healthy.
You're pro. Gotcha. Yeah. Um,
I can't believe the fucking money
I used to blow when I was a kid.
I used to make 260 bucks a
week, right? My only expense.
Why had I had a car payment? 130 $838
and 62 cents. I still remember it.
And uh,
that was it.
And gas that was making 260 bucks.
And I was t that was my take home.
260 bucks a week, right? So what's that?
860 times four is two 40 I was making
over grand a month and I'd be fucking
broke every Wednesday.
Fucking idiot. I swear to God,
if I was a miser,
I might as well have been a miser.
This is what the fuck I should've done.
Tell it was going out in
the clubs and crushing it.
Coming out with my fucking orange Afro.
Hey ladies.
I mean, it was a shit show. It was
Charlie Brown trying to kick the football.
It was like Atlanta trying to
win a champion job. Come on bill.
Come on. The new Cleveland Ladies
and gentlemen, all of a sudden,
Cleveland wins a fucking basketball
championship and the entire country's and
the cubs won. How nervous were
you down there in La and Atlanta?
You know what I mean? Atlanta. I
came to say it this morning. Atlanta.
Atlanta. How fucking nervous, where you
Cleveland winds. You're like, Oh shit,
all we got less the cubs,
you know,
maybe if the Indians win,
then they went to champions.
Cleveland winds two
championships in a year.
The cubs is still the fucking sad
sacks at like 108 years or whatever.
And then they went three in a row.
The cubs win it and the entire
sporting world just stops,
turns around and stares at
Atlanta Quiver and over in the corner.
Like, hey guys, you know, for the record,
the Braves one at 95,
it's got to count for something.
Right? Oh, those poor bastards.
You,
I just connected in a,
I connected in with the fuck
was I in, um, in Atlanta.
And I saw this woman walked by and she
had on a falcons hat and I was like,
you know what, good for, there's a real
fan still wearing the Atlanta shit. Right.
And it was a red hat, but then I also
noticed that she was wearing red sneakers,
you know what I mean? And she then, she
was also African American and I was just,
and I just assumed she didn't give a fuck.
I learned that from Patrice O'Neil
the first time I saw them with like an
islanders hat on. Right. I was like,
Oh fuck man, you like the islanders.
He was like, what? I go,
you liked the islanders.
And he took off his hat and looked at,
he goes, Nah man, I don't give a shit.
I goes, I, he goes,
I just liked the colors and these pair
of fucking islanders covered colored
sneakers on. You told me to
say, Bill Black people don't
give a fuck about, I mean,
I'm not saying generally, you know,
hey, we got all the white guy.
I've got to fucking make sure I fucking
say this correctly. He was saying,
generally speaking, we wear this shit
because of colors. It's not, you know,
and he joked, he just fuck it. Yeah.
He trashed me all the fucking time.
So anyways,
so I looked at her and I did that.
Patrice conversation just popped into
my fucking head and I was just like,
as she probably just probably just needed
a hat to go with those fucking shoes.
Supposed to white people where
were the same fucking hat forever.
It's all frayed and shit.
Walking around with your cargo
pants and your flip flops.
I don't think I'll ever get over
fucking northern Florida. I know,
I've heard a zillion jokes about it,
but Jesus fucking Christ,
Jesus fucking Christ.
There are some characters out there.
And what's amazing is
it's absolutely gorgeous.
And then there's people
with like beautiful homes
in money, but they're there.
I swear to God, isn't me.
There's no middle-class.
It's like when you go to a third
world country, it's just like this,
just fucking people living in this crazy
poverty and then they'll just be this
mansion. I Dunno. Anyway, well,
you know,
probably didn't help that I fucking went
to the Daytona 500 bunch of Yahoos like
me. And by the way, I fit right in. I
fucking fit right in. I'm, I'm, you know,
I don't know. I should be
more white collar. But uh,
due to some financial reasons, I
had a very fucking, you know, I'm,
I'm pretty much a put
it this way. I, it was,
it wasn't until I hung out with a
bunch of, of poetry stories here.
I wasn't until I hung out with Patrice
that I realized that macaroni and cheese
wasn't a main dish.
We used to have all of that shit.
Macaroni and cheese with toast
was a meal and I fucking loved it.
Get half a tray just scooping that
shit out was the craft. I've told you.
Talk to you guys about this
chicken Alec King on toast.
Chipped beef on toast.
I fucking hated that shit.
Chicken Alan King was also
gross. Um, those are the, yeah.
You know, in mother's work and
she comes home, she's got 90 kids,
opens up a couple of cans, throws it
in a pot and make some toast. Yay.
You're fucking animals.
Um, anyways, chef boy yard d.
Okay.
You know, when I think
back, this was born,
we didn't know anything about
fucking nutrition back then. TV.
We weren't never really
big on the TV dinners.
And I remember I used to
ask my mother to get them.
I think that there was something,
I don't what the fuck was called
Hungry Jack's or some shit.
Something that had jack in it.
It sounded manly, you know,
and the commercials all you know,
big chunks and Turkey with gravy Matt of,
and I was sitting there going
[inaudible] that looks fucking delicious.
Okay.
I Dunno. We just never, we never,
we weren't, we never, we didn't,
we didn't cross that line
with the fast food. You know,
I remember steak hymns, those were
my favorites. I'd be sitting in,
I would be sitting not paying attention
in the last three periods of school when
I was in a middle school, junior
high, whatever the fuck you call it.
Just thinking about the state of that
I was going to make when I got home.
That's all I gave a felt. That
was a game changer. You know,
kid from the seventies eighties you know,
you came home,
your parents weren't home, right.
Latch key kid, you come home.
The game changer was when you went from
making something just room temperature
or cold to actually get in the,
you know,
the next level. It's like
moving up in like a, you know,
army ranks as Scientology,
whatever.
When you get to a new level
of security clearance, okay,
you can use the fucking frying pan and
all of a sudden you had a fucking hot
meal.
I used to cook those fuckers up,
put them on white bread and then you had
to eat it real quick because the grease,
there was so much fucking grease from
whatever cut of meat. Was it squirrel?
I didn't know what the fuck it was.
It was such a shit cut of meat that the
grease would just be coming through the
bread. It was, it was fucking gross
push. You put ketchup on and shit.
Sorry if I'm grossing. Yeah.
Let me get off the subject.
I gotta. I gotta address all the
fucking who and whom police. Oh my God.
That's like a whole cult within itself.
The level of fucking arrogance that people
came and the joy that they had that I
see that I'm not good at.
Who in home you would think that you
could actually make money off of that?
Like they had a hot
stock tip or some shit.
Hey this fucking company's going to
go public. You didn't hear it from me.
This is one thing that I learned.
I think I finally figured out,
cause people told me this trick before,
it's like if you could substitute he or
she use who you know him or her use home
some like to whom do I have the pleasure
of speaking to and I'm like to him,
I have the pleasure of,
of speaking with,
I wouldn't say that that sentence doesn't
work to she do I have the pleasure of
speaking.
Yeah.
Okay.
Like I don't fucking get it. But then
it's like, no, who you speaking to?
You would say to him, to her. Then I
was like, oh, that's what they mean.
I thought the, I thought you just meant
take out a who are home and plug in.
He or she
who did this shit, he did this shit.
I get it. I think I just got it.
I think I finally
cracked the fucking code.
But here's the deal with
who and wants the deal. Woo.
Here's the deal with that shit.
Nobody says whom out loud unless
you're teaching an English class.
No one says that.
Right? It's always hope. Who the
fuck do I? You know, it's not.
To whom am I speaking? Was I,
what the fuck am I talking to? Oh,
the fuck are you?
Who am I fucking speaking with?
Yeah,
it's speaking to fucking him. That's why
you said fuck it home. Oh, all right,
thanks Jerry. Nobody says it out loud,
but it's one of those things if you,
if you don't write it
correctly, you know, if you,
people flip the fuck out and they
judge you like you're a fucking more,
but I've never heard
anybody, you know, that's,
that's another one that's, that's
another like security level. You go past,
if you start out loud
using the not not writing,
okay.
Speaking and you use the word whom like
you've alienated probably 80% of the
population of my country.
And I don't think that there's a bigger
example of the gap between wealth and
regular people than using whom in
public. I always picture that. I
know you know something
even that you know,
because there's people that fucking rob
and steal their way into the upper 1%
and then they just a fucking dope
like me still. But if you're born,
if you're born into that shit,
if you've got some trust
fund hanging over your head,
if you one of those kids and
you have to learn how to fence,
take a fencing fucking class in college
to show that you're a gentleman.
You know,
did you walk around with the
date rape drug in your pocket?
Cause your dad knows a judge and can
get you off and you wear loafers with no
socks. Right? There's a
bunch of stereotypes. Um,
I was speaking to that, me and the, I got
this fucking monster debate last night.
She take this show, she goes,
she goes, Hey, I take this show.
It's about rappers in Paris. You know, you
ought to check this out. So I was like,
all right, I'm going to
watch this shit. Right.
So immediately they show in these
guys and they're rapping and French.
I don't know what this saying. So you
know, I'm trying to read the words.
I'm a dope. It's going by too fast.
But it sounds a lot like, you know,
it's the same sort of point of
view as a lot of rappers over here,
which I am in a the minority group.
I'm getting treated like shit.
I'm living in the shittiest part of the
fucking city. A lot of that stuff. Right.
But it's flying by because
I can't read fast enough.
So they got this fucking nerdy white
kid goes to interview this dude, um,
who's Muslim and he's living
in some part in Paris. Right.
And he's talking about all of this stuff
that's happening to him now. Right.
And uh, no, the first
thing he talked about,
he said that he was talking about how um,
he said thank God that he found, you
know, rap and he did that, cause you know,
he could've gone the other way.
He said, I could've become a bomb.
That's what he said. So the white dude
goes like, oh, you mean like, you know,
you would've blown some people
up or something like that.
And then the dude's basically like,
I knew you're going to take it that way.
That's not how I meant it. That's
really offensive. And I, you know,
and he's speaking through an interpreter,
tell him if he's going to come
down here and talk to people,
he needs to check the way he's
talking to people, blah, blah.
And I'm just sitting there going like,
you totally set him up for that.
That was like fucking attracted. What
do you think? He's going to think?
Okay.
So Nia goes, well, he's not doing that.
So you know,
he gets judged because of those
actions of the few of the few.
And it's just like, I understand
that. I totally understand that,
but at some point you have to address
the fucking elephant in the room,
don't you?
You know?
Yeah.
Like when people,
like when I travel outside of this country
and people treat me like shit because
I'm an American, I don't act like
that just fell out of the sky.
I know where that's coming from.
The pure listic way that we've
colonized the entire fucking world,
the amount of time we've,
we've cited with dictators because
they've given us fucking oil is they're
oppressed in their own PD amount of times
we've been on the wrong fucking side
of shit. It's like an a walk around like,
well, I didn't show it. That's like,
you know,
as much as it's still wrong to judge me,
I understand that when I walk out of
the House, I'm no longer me anymore.
It's teams. It's like red
sox and Yankees. Okay,
and you're low and you're fucking the hat,
the team hat you're wearing is you skin.
Okay.
And people are going to
judge you for that. You know,
back when I had here and I came walking
down the street looking like fucking
Richie Cunningham,
you know,
I knew that people were looking at
me like that, you know, like fucking
[inaudible]. I can take this kid's
lunch money, look at his fucking hair.
Okay,
does it make it right?
Absolutely does not make it right.
But to sit there and act like you
don't know where shit is coming from.
That's what drives me nuts.
And it's like I completely understand
that on my side to have empathy for that
guy.
But what was pissing me off was there
was no empathy coming from the other side
being like, listen, I
understand. You know,
cause there was no understanding of that,
that wrapper that this guy is
totally on the outside looking in.
So he's going to come from this fear-based
fucking thing that he's, you know,
from the shit that he sees in the
media and the media is basically,
you get judged all groups of people,
you get judged by the Jerry Springer
fucking group of your people.
That's basically it. So with white
people, we're either living in a trailer,
fucking our sister or where these lizard
people shapeshifters that live under a
fucking mountain. Illuminati
is essentially it, right?
There's a lot. This is a zillion of
them. We were in a fucking eight group.
We're in the fucking clan, we
got have, we got a four wheeler,
we're shooting a gun or whatever.
Right.
And you've got all those
fucking stereotypes, um,
which obviously is not
a fair fucking thing.
And I also wanted to stand
that despite those stereotypes,
the Matrix is made for white people.
So I this spite those,
it really doesn't affect my life and I
get all of that type of shit. But I mean,
I dunno, I just needed that guy in the
moment to just be like, you know what?
I understand why you said
that. You know, rather than,
than just immediately go into lecture
mode because then when you're sitting at
home, I don't know if you're like
me, I just plugged myself in. Well,
who would I be in that scenario? Oh,
I'd be that guy getting a lecture.
So I just started saying all this shit.
I would've said back to him and it drove
my fucking wife up the wall. She's like,
why can't you just watch
things? It's like, you know I,
what do you mean why can't I,
the TV's interacted to me the same shit
I do when I watch wheel of fortune and I
make fun of every contestant and you
sitting there laughing your ass off and I
turned it into this like a comedy show.
You then get mad at me when I do the
same fucking thing when I'm watching this
other shit. And so I, we just
made a truce. It's like, don't,
I don't want to watch any of any shit
with you that has to do with this stuff
because we're going to end up in a
fucking argument because I'm going to act
like I'm watching wheel of fortune.
Um, anyways, why is this thing bing bang
and booming and all that type of shit.
You know,
having said all that,
I completely understood where that
guy was coming from. It's like, yeah,
I didn't do any of that shit. You know,
I'm trying to get the fuck outta here.
I've lived in this country my whole
life and I never felt like it was mine.
Okay. Which is, you know, and this is
the arrogant thing that I'm going to do,
not even living over there,
I'm going to chastise white people like,
cause we do it here.
You can't do that to people.
You can't have people living in the
country their whole fucking lives.
And the our American, they are French
and all that. You cannot treat them like,
yeah, but you know, you know, you're
not real American American. It's like,
well fucking neither were you then you're
European or whatever the fuck you're
from. Um, so I don't know.
I'm not, I'm not a fucking,
I like to think I'm not a fucking bad guy.
I get all of that type of shit.
But Jesus Christ at some point,
you know,
like I used to joke right after nine
11 and they started racially profiling
Arabs and all that, which was completely
fucked up. And I understood it,
but I never heard it. Like I just
always looked at it like, all right,
if 20 red heads knocked down
some skyscrapers, you know,
I'd expect to be getting some
looks that next day at the airport.
Does it make it right? But I
wouldn't be sitting there going, oh,
I completely understand
where this is coming from.
And I don't like it cause I'm an it.
I'm an innocent guy.
But I would have the empathy to at least
address where the fear is coming from.
And it's,
I think that if you just fucking do that,
the other side can relax and
maybe listen to your point,
you know,
because that's what happened to me when
I watched that and I watched that kid
all of a sudden get a lecture after
that guy said I'd turned my s I could've
become a bomb.
And I just felt he set the fucking kid
up and then I immediately went into
defense mode defending that kid. And I
know, and I didn't even at that point,
sit and listen to what this guy had to
say. So then I didn't learn anything.
I would equate that to like, you know,
when people make, try to make a point,
like when people were trying
to teach me who and home.
So much of it started
with, hey, fuck head,
maybe you should try blood. Um,
how do I get past? Hey, fuck it.
I don't know. I like to think that
there was a decent point made in there.
I'm sure I'll get a bunch of shit
for that. But um, either way,
it was an interesting
debate, you know, hey,
I bought those fucking Boston Celtics
had beat the Cleveland Cavaliers.
What a God's name is a cavalier.
There's probably some fucking
fancy name for white oppressor.
Wait a second,
Kev.
I know you can act cavalier
if your cavalier attitude,
can you ever have a cavalier
attitude and it's like a fucking,
you'll get good thing.
Cavalier is like,
that's like a happy go lucky
upper 1% or you know what I mean?
Like if they were broke,
they be,
they be ob Taylor with the fucking
stick over the shoulder with the little
little fish hook on it. You know,
just going to go skip some rocks.
But all of a sudden,
you know,
if you cavalier and you're in the upper
1% is a white dude. That means a, I dunno,
there's a bunch of kids digging for
fucking m diamonds. I don't fucking know.
Let me look this up. Okay
hottie disdainful. I, because
I was Ron Hardy. Disdainful
or supercilious.
I don't know what that word is.
An arrogant and cavalier
attitude towards other, offhand
Cleveland Cavaliers is, is it
anything, it's gotta be something else.
Yeah. Are they really the Cleveland
arrogant concepts that what they,
they named themselves. It can't be
that. It's got a horseman there. It is.
Especially a mounted soldier a night.
Yeah. Oppressive, oppressive wire.
White Guy.
Uh,
one having this spirit
or bearing of a knight.
A courtly gentleman galleon.
These guys are arrogant.
Huh?
A man escorting a woman or acting
as their partner in dancing.
All right. We'll just slowly
get into the NBA lifestyle here.
They're coming out of the shower and all
the whores hanging out waiting to get
him his fucking magic. Johnson used
to say, you got chastised for that.
These women, they're out to get you after
the show. Oh, that's offensive to women,
not the horse. That's who I
was talking about. Sweetheart,
go back to your soccer mom. Pay
with your red wine. Thank you.
Um,
okay.
And a adherent of an adherent of Charles,
the first of England in
his contest with the pound.
It's amazing that I speak this language
in so many words that I've just never
seen before and have no idea
how to pronounce. All right.
As an adjective hottie disdainful.
And that's supercilious whatever
the fuck that is. Um, offhand,
that's a good name for a fucking dance.
Like one of those meatpacking district
dance clubs I got, I got down at,
it's sell us last night. Am I old
girlfriend? Totally fucking outdated.
And apparently, yeah. Oh No. Getting
onto the transplant. All right.
Offhand or unceremonious
of a relating to the Cavaliers.
That's a fucking lazy
definition of relating to a
characteristic of the cavalier
poets or their work. All right.
I don't know what a cavalier is.
This is either a gentleman,
a knight, a poet,
or a cunt. You know, one of the other,
I guess it depends if you
live in Cleveland or not.
They probably think they're a bunch of
gentlemen. They're not yet animals. Oh,
those, that's a special kind of animal
that lives up there in Cleveland.
You know what I mean?
You know why that Lake caught on fire?
It wasn't the lake of Zuora.
You know what it was because so many of
those animals walked into it and bathed.
That's what happened.
They took that beautiful water yeah.
That God made and they turned
it into something flammable.
I'm just kidding.
Yeah.
They always say that mistake by the
lake and they always say that lake eerie
caught on fire. It didn't catch on fire.
It was, it was way more understandable.
It was like a,
I think it was a whatever the runoff that
went into the city and they were just
dumping all their pollution into it. They
didn't light a great lake on fire. Um,
I dunno. But now with all that
fracking, the FRAC and down the road,
Shit, I go to get it my goddamn above
ground pool. Next thing you know,
I'm having a fucking,
except I'm the main course.
Okay
Sir. We understand
that, uh, you are upset,
but we don't feel that our company has
anything to do with your above ground
pool catching on fire. Oh,
fuck you in your soup buddy.
Okay.
Um, all right, let's read some advertising
here for this week. Dirty Lemon.
That sounds the only stupid fucking
jokes. Hey, that dirty Sanchez.
You know those fucking joke book jokes
and everybody seems to love for fucking
real. When you fucking take
a piece of road speech,
slap her in the tit and then you come
on a foot. Oh, is that what it's called?
Doing those jokes.
She's got called the f the get the fuck
Outta here cause I don't wanna hear
anymore. That's stupid. It get really ugly
dude. Rub One out and just fucking
relax with you. Knock Knock Dick Jokes.
All right.
Dirty Lemon.
Dirty lemon is a wellness beverage brand
featuring ingredients that have been
well established in the, Oh God.
He's another English word. Cancer.
A net ne natural pathic
community nature. Oh. Pathic
naturopathic
knit Toora paddock.
Anyway, so there's three types of
these fucking things right now. Sleep,
detox in skin plus hair. Oh
Shit. I might get some of this.
And each one contains the
juice of one lemon, no sugar,
and it's under 10 calories. I have
no idea what the fuck this stuff is.
There's sleep drink for example,
includes magnesium.
Was there anything grosser than milk
of magnesium when you were a kid?
You need some milk of magnesium
came in that blue bottle.
What was that supposed to do?
Coat your esophagus.
Okay.
Was that for a fucking sword?
Swallower um,
probably a lot of that
backstage at the circus.
And each one contains the juice of one
lemon. No sugar in is under 10 calories.
Their sleep drink for example, includes
magnesium rosewater and camel meal,
which all help you sleep better.
Evidently I drank one the other night
before bed and I slept like a bear.
Okay.
Why, why wouldn't you send me
this product first and I would,
uh, say something about
better dreams. Oh, okay.
So when I didn't drink this
thing and I slept like a bear,
I had this fucking amazing dream that uh,
uh,
I don't know,
pick one of these fucking starlets was
fucking ride my deck and the Detox is
secretly great hangover cure.
Oh, now you are in my wheelhouse.
Drink a bottle and the activated
charcoal absorbs toxins in your body.
I would like a 12 pack of that police.
But the best part about dirty lemon is
that the only way to order is via text
message. You'll never find
it in stores. Jesus Christ.
This is some underground shit to order.
Go to dirty lemon.com.
Register your mobile number,
then send them a text message.
Say it all to a real human.
And after a few texts,
a six pack is sent to your door in one
to two days. Once you buy via text,
you'll never want to go back. When
you text them, mentioned your hurt.
I'm going to fucking get some of this
shit and I'm going to go out and I'm going
to drink a bunch of fucking Tequila
or some shit and I'm going to,
so I'm going to see if it works.
That'd be great.
Sitting here with a fucking wife
and a beautiful baby. You know,
you've given me shit for getting drunk.
It's like, Nah, I'm researching a product.
Um,
when you text them,
mentioned you heard about it on my podcast
and they'll throw in an extra case of
the sleep drink for free with your
first or a 12 bottles for the prices.
Six for more information.
Checkout dirty lemon.com for other
morons out there. Lemon is spelled l.
E. M. O. N. Not e. N. Not I, n. Not UN.
Lemon.
All right,
come on. You guys are a bunch
of drugs like me, aren't you?
Would you like a little check and
you're fucking Sass Barilla there all
distilled genes. Great genes don't have
to be complicated. Where is the zipper?
If you're not into crazy
stitching diamonds or embedded
studs, you're not alone.
Oh yeah. Remember those true
religion jeans? Jesus Christ.
There's so many people that got those
and knocked up a chicken and now dad's
pushing strollers around those fucking
true religion jeans with the stitched
horseshoe on the fucking ass pockets and
then the lining down this side. Yeah,
that's standing. That's pushing
somebody on a swing right now,
I'll afraid at the bottom.
Um,
there's still jeans pronounced.
The stilt offers luxury grade
denim at an affordable price.
Jeans that would normally cost you
hundreds distilled start at just 75 bucks.
These are great jeans. I've actually
tried these on. I enjoyed them.
They felt great around my balls and seq
area. Um, they utilize the same fabrics,
factories in wash houses as the best
known brands and designers who works in
those places.
Where do you work?
I work in a denim wash house.
Okay.
I make 30 cents a day while skipping the
markups and middlemen the result. Pure,
unadulterated denim without
the retail run around.
Just go to distill.com
spelled d, e s t, l, d,
um,
Delta Sierra,
Tango Lima,
delta.com and see where minimalist
design meets maximum comfort.
They guarantee the fit. They'll ship
them to you for free. It give you,
give you free returns, gross.
You'll find fts, sweat them up,
sweat up in a fucking cross country
flight. You can send it back.
They don't care until you find.
The perfect pair of distilled has been
featured in Forbes time and tech crunch
as well as on denim clad celebrities
and GQ and vogue distilled as the only
place that the US,
you can get this quality of this
quality of denim for this price.
You can find their amazing
selection of outerwear,
leather jackets and tee shirts
to go on Rob Helford here,
and more using some of the same principles
of high grade materials at low end
costs. Even celebrities are wearing
distilled. We're not going to name any,
we're just gonna throw that
out there. I've got a pair. Oh,
I guess I'm supposed to be talking
about myself. I've got a pair of the,
I don't know what style it is.
They fit perfect.
They were a little long in the leg, but
I, you know, what are you going to do?
There's still does your answer to Ella
to elevated style without elevated prices
. Just Jesus fucking Christ.
Let's get to the end here.
Just go to distill.com/bar right
now and get 10% off your first pair.
That's distilled.com d s t l D
m.com/burn for 10% off right now, five
letters, Delta Sierra, tango, Lima,
delta.com/berg how many fucking more? Oh
Jesus. Two more. Two more. Hang in there.
Oh, but it'll boat boat
me on. These me undies.
Walk around in my jeans, but do
do, do me undies me on these.
My balls are dry,
if you know what I mean.
I put that cotton that put
the modal up on my tape.
My balls are dry. Ah,
don't say they ain't.
I always say that half fucking
taint. What else? Rinds with taint.
Um, taint eight st of, there you go.
Put that modal up against my tape.
The Catholic Church.
She has made me a say because I love
the other way as they banged a kid.
Nobody gives a fuck. It wasn't all
of them. How can you still go there?
All right.
I'm the undies.
Elevate the underwear game to
the next level with me undies.
You've perfected your wardrobe.
You even have a fucking cake.
But what about the stuff?
Not everybody gets to see if you've been
settling for store bought underwear,
five packs. I have something
that will change your life for,
for the better me undies.
What's the first thing you put
on the last thing you take off?
It's your underwear. Unless you, Matthew
mcconaughey, he doesn't wear underwear.
All right. All right. All right. It comes
in with his dick hanging out. All right.
All right.
Make your most important piece of clothing
the best it can be with me on these.
Mandy's are designed in La and made from
sustainable source micro micro model,
modality. They fucking that
they're cutting it up man.
Now fabric three times softer than cotton.
Biondi softer than soft lugs.
I on dcis as supposed to be luxury
luxury undies come in and ever changing
selection of classic colors,
bold shapes and adventurous patterns.
So you can tailor your undies to your
own personal style. And guess what?
You can save time and more money
and money each month with a monthly
subscription. If you're not ready for
a strip subscription, that's okay.
You can still save.
That's because we undies is offering
you 20% off your first pair.
Just use our special URL, [inaudible]
dot com slash Berg at 20% off first pair.
So go ahead revamp your underwear
drawer. You deserve it. Once again,
that's me on these.com/ [inaudible]
dot com slash bar lastly,
but not leastly.
And after this I'll talk about fucking
Aaron Kaufman leaving gas monkey garage.
Cause I know there's a lot of, you watch
that show like me. Okay. Alright. Oh,
legalzoom,
everybody.
National small business
month@legalzoom.com is here
and its timing couldn't be
any.
Yeah.
Approval rates for business loans are
up and so was consumer confidence,
but it takes a lot more than good
timing to launch a successful business.
That's why legal zoom created
a free business startup kit.
Part of being an entrepreneur is
utilizing the right resources to help you
succeed. Oh, I thought it was
listening to the broke ass.
People give you great ideas and then you
say you don't like it on shark tank and
then you secretly do it around,
around the back or you buy it for way
less than you should've paid them.
Isn't that an I own it.
I own the patent. Um,
you can't be an expert at everything.
So go to legalzoom.com start up today
and download your free sat up kit.
You'll get an educational ebooks and
legal zoom discounts to save money setting
up your business.
Plus you can save thousands of dollars
through legal zooms partners to offer
offers to help with financing,
marketing, and day to day operations,
things you'll need to run a successful
business. Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but they're dedicated to making
life easier for business owners.
Whether you're thinking of starting a
business or already run one, go to legal
zoom.com/startup during National Small
Business Ma Ma Ma Ma to take advantage of
your free business startup kit. That's
legal zoom.com/startup ah, right.
Hey, by the way, I,
I actually filmed a bunch of shit at
Daytona Five Daytona 500 I filmed some
stuff when I was in Gainesville,
Georgia. I uploaded it.
I sent it to my podcast guy
who's now going to edit it.
I'm actually going to follow through and
we should have a couple of videos for
you on my,
on my new fucking youtube page,
youtube.com/user/monday morning podcast.
Once again,
www.youtube.com/users/monday
morning podcast.
I'm going to start doing
those city tours again.
I wanna make little stupid videos.
I'm going to get that fucking thing going.
Speaking of which, I'm going to
be in Phoenix this week, Monday,
Tuesday and Wednesday, flying in Sunday
night to see the fucking Celtics,
Isaiah Thomas p against the
Phoenix Suns there on Sunday night.
I'll see you guys at the game.
Um, oh, I'd also like to thank uh,
some people at the, uh, Tampa Bay
lightning for hooking me in forest.
Shot up with some tickets.
We got to see a Nikita coop giraffe get
a hat trick against the Ottawa senators.
It was a great fucking game, great
fucking game. You know, Tampa,
Tampa Bay came out and it was like they
were fucking owning them and then all of
a sudden auto it goes, hey
gee, they're easy there.
And then they took control of the
game and then after the fucking,
the first intermission,
I don't know what the,
I don't know what sort of a third
time adjustments that they used.
It's not half time for all you non hockey
fans who try to say that there's two
half times in hockey, you know, that
always makes me feel smart. I'm like,
mathematically that doesn't make sense.
There's a third and then there's
two thirds through the game.
And if you ever played pickup
hockey three on fucking three,
if you've ever fucking done that and you
look at of, there's no substitutions,
you know why? You would know
why they take two breaks. Okay?
Then a fucking lollygagging around like
a bunch of baseball players and they
just need to stretch once every
seven 30 there is sprinting.
Someone could beat the shit out of you
and just sit down for five minutes. Okay.
You're going to need to take a couple
of breaks. All right, let's talk.
Gas Monkey garage.
Um,
Monday nights episode was the episode
that they'd been teasing the whole,
the whole fucking season.
The shit that you read about on social
media before the season even started.
The bearded wonder Aaron
Kaufman came back from vacation.
Eh, he fucking just, he
straight up quit. It wasn't,
he didn't give notice. A, I'll help you
on a couple of builds. He was just like,
I am out. It's been a great
run. I'll fucking see you later.
And,
uh,
I'm Richard Rollins as
always was hilarious.
It's like I feel like I'm going to Puke.
Okay.
Can you go?
Oh he's only said that a few times
during the series and it's always fucking
hilarious cause I feel like
the word puke is kind of,
that's like from my generation. Like he
graduated high school the same year. I,
I watched the show a lot.
I'm not a psycho, but he,
he mentions all the time he built
that fucking, that mercury comment.
You mentioned that he graduated
high school in 87 and a
I should've graduated in
86, but we're not going to talk. Why,
why I didn't because I'm a cause you
cause you heard cause you hear me read out
loud. It should've happened in 86. It
was exciting. I'm a year older than him,
but puke. I just feel like nobody
says that. I never hear it.
I don't hear it enough. And he's only said
it a couple times. He said it lat, uh,
on Monday when Aaron quit going to
Puke and he said it when he bought that
Ferrari that had been in that major
accident. And it was like his big,
this giant investment, like 300
grand. He went in with the other,
the fucking rich dude up the street
who likes all the European stuff.
I don't know why,
I can't remember his name.
I only seen him in fucking 9,000 episodes.
And afterwards he was,
he was so fucking nervous. He was talking
about just, I feel like I'm gonna Puke.
I don't know why. It always
makes me laugh. So anyways, um,
as a fan of the show, you
know, it was like watching
van Halen break up. It's like,
ah, fuck, now they're going
to bring in, you know,
some other guy who was in David Lee Roth,
not shitting on Sammy Hagar, you know,
I'm just saying, you know what I mean,
you like the be want the original guy.
So I was actually happy that they,
they for the rest of the episode.
So they was showing Aaron at his
house and he was doing this build.
It was fucking hilarious and everything
fit engine went in, transmission,
everything fucking winded fine.
Um,
and then he just got up and took a
break and went over and was feeding his
horses and I'm just like, oh, here you
go. Although when he was, you know,
he was trying to make this race car
and he was taking all this shit out,
you know, that they don't need
so he can make it lighter,
watching him have to do that by himself.
I bet that kind of sucked. But, um,
I'm just hoping as a fan that Aaron
gets his own shows cause I read a really
good interview and it
wasn't all this he said,
she said Shit,
it just seemed like he wanted to do
more adventurous builds of cars that,
you know, when you're not on a
TV show, you know what I mean?
You're kind of under the constraint.
He was just saying how fast
they will build in cars,
kind of limited what they could do.
And uh,
I think that that was probably
the reason why he left.
Just got a little burnt out or whatever.
But um,
it's fucking brutal, man. I mean that was
the guy. So we'll see what happens. But
I have faith, I have faith that they're
going to find someone to replace him.
And I'm hoping that I'm going
to get two shows out of it. Um,
I dunno, but whatever. It's definitely
the end of, of a Goddamn era.
And, uh, I'm trying to think of my,
my favorite builds that
they've done on that show. Um,
I always liked the random
shit that they did.
I've mentioned this before.
I love when they did that low rider and
I can't remember if it was one of those
like a 85 Oldsmobile cutlass or something.
I love that they just gave Casey a chance
to fucking show off what he could do.
And he was shown all that different
kind of steady just painting it black or
green. But I understand that
they always say, you know,
those are the two colors that sell and
you gotta make you fucking money. But, um,
there was another time they built
this car, can't remember what it was,
and it was this white car and on top,
Casey did this lace thing on the hood,
on Msre on the roof.
I fucking love that.
Um,
did they have a fucking
Lincoln continental?
I've always loved the random
shit as opposed to the,
uh, the more obvious stuff.
I love that fucking mercury comment that
they made, although I gotta tell you,
I like to fucking white and blue color
scheme better when they first had it and
I liked those rims better,
but if they just did all the gas monkey
shit underneath it and slammed it down
to the ground, that's a fucking killer.
Cock. I don't know. I like weird shit.
Um,
and my biggest heartbreak on that show
was one time when Richard Rawlings blot
that fucking cab over engine truck, that
jeepers creepers truck. And I was like,
oh my God, what the fuck are they
going to do to this? And then he just,
somebody came in like, the next day
I'll give you an extra two grand for,
he's like, I fuck it. Get outta here.
And I was just like, what the hell?
I want to see them build more trucks. I
hope they do. Um, all right. That's it.
Uh,
so good luck to Aaron Kaufman.
I hope I see him on another
TV show or whatever. I,
I should give a shout out to his.
Um, he's got, um, he has his own,
he's got his own a, um, company, I guess
that builds parts for, believe it or not,
Ford f one hundreds. What? I have 68
FordF 100 and I believe it's called,
I think it's called arclight. Just
look up, uh, Aaron Kaufman, arclight.
And uh, you'll actually find that
article. I should put a link to it.
It's a really good article
about, um, why he left the show.
And I thought I was happy that it wasn't
a bunch of mudslinging or anything like
that.
It just seemed like it was time and he
wanted to go in a different directions.
So, so that's it. Um, that is the
podcast for this fucking week.
Um, no, it isn't this, that's
just me checking in on you.
I'll do the real podcast on Monday.
This is not a real podcast. All right.
That said, go fuck yourselves.
Have a great weekend.
You've constant joy of the music and
equals doing an extra half hour above
greatest hits from a podcast
in a fucking Monday gone by.
Well,
we were
[inaudible].
So anyways,
I went up to see some family over the
4th of July to celebrate the birthday of
this country. And, uh, as I'm driving up,
I'm listening on the radio and
evidently I looked up the song on,
uh,
on the Internet.
Okay.
It's a, uh, Carrie Underwood song, who
I don't, I don't know what she has.
I'm guessing she's white cause it sounded
country and she had a little Twang in
her voice, but I don't want to
piss off any Koreans out there.
She might've been Korean,
um,
as a song called before he cheats.
So I'm driving a log and you know,
I'm driving my buddy's car.
This is how I'm going to
fucking defend myself.
That I was on a radio station that was
actually playing this and I was just sort
of clicking the, uh,
the preprogram radios,
fucking whatever. You know what I'm
saying? I'm home, I'm feel like shit.
Cut me some slack this week. So
anyways, this song comes on and this,
this Carrie Underwood CIC is sitting
there singing this song going a rat.
Now he's probably slow dancing.
I have a bed Pratt now and she's
singing about her boyfriend.
I got the lyrics right here right now.
He's probably buying her some fruity
little drink cause she can't shoot whiskey
right now. He's probably up
behind her with the pool stick,
showing her how to shoot a combo.
And then they go into the chorus
and she goes and he don't know,
um,
that I dug my keys into the side of his
pretty little souped up four wheel drive
car of my name and to his leather seats.
I took a Louisville
slugger to both headlights,
slashed a hole in all four tires.
And all I could think was,
why don't you just break up with them?
You dumb cunt.
You know what I mean?
What are you going to do?
You're going to do all this shit.
Then he's going to get mad and then what
you're going to make up after five days
and then you're going to blow him again.
I hate this fucking song and I'm going
to tell you why, because it's, I,
I'm pretty sure it's a hit.
It's on the radio, right? Uh,
I dunno.
And you,
what do I love about this is people will
listen to this song and they won't even
question the rationale of what
the fuck someone's doing in there.
Because so many people in life,
myself included,
you, you, you, you play,
you like powerless in life.
You just play the powerless card,
you know,
just get out of the fucking relationship.
I fucking hate this song.
And this is one of these songs too.
We're fucking women all get together.
They start singing, hey guy,
cat, I don't even ask her.
You're all a bunch of dumb cunts.
Okay, you're fucking stupid.
Just break up with the guy.
Just break up with them.
Not even to mention the fact that now
you're going out there and you're,
you're, you're doing damage. You, I don't
know, is that a fella that's not a felony?
I don't know what it is,
but it's just a classic thing where a
woman would listen to that song and at no
point would she ever think, man,
maybe I could get arrested for this.
I am damaging somebody's property.
No, you got fucking vagina.
You can just go out in broad daylight.
You don't even have to
wear a fucking mask.
Do you know what I would have to do
if I wanted to go out and go fuck up
somebody's car? I would have
to wait for the, first of all,
I had to make sure I had an alibi.
It'd be like I was killing somebody.
I had to make sure somebody could
cover for me and say that I was fucking
somewhere.
Right.
I had to put on some goddamn cat
suit and a fucking a mask. Right?
Like I'm in there dead presidents
movie and all I would able to get,
I'd be able to get off one quick
hit, right? One quick kid, let's,
I want to start carving it up
like a pussy. Right? But if I,
if I really was going to go out there
and smash somebodies head lights,
I can hit one and the second
the car alarm goes off,
I have to fucking take
off and then run home,
get out of my little fucking fucking a
little cat suit and then try to put on my
pajamas.
So when the cops show up,
because you know they're going to
find some sort of fucking fingerprint,
I got to act like I'm not out of breath.
Like I actually have been sitting there
for fucking eight hours watching TV.
I Dunno, I just, I can't stand, you know,
it just reminds me of when that movie,
a fatal attraction came out,
right.
And the amount of women who would just sit
there and you see that movie, Eh? Yeah.
That's what you get.
And as t yet, you know,
there's no thought of like
this bitch put a rabbit in,
in boiling water.
There's none of that women there.
They're out of their fucking minds.
But that's not even the point of this.
My point of the Carrie Underwood song,
it actually made me feel like a loser
because the amount of fucking times,
I mean I haven't gone out
and fucked up somebody's car,
but the amount of times you don't,
what does that song is that song,
it's a powerless song.
That's what the fuck it is.
And I went to the whole lyrics to see if
she breaks up with them in the end and
there's sort of an ambiguous line in
the end where she goes a cause the next
time he cheats, oh you
know, it won't be on me.
So that's sort of ambiguous because it
could mean because I broke up with them
or it could be because he doesn't
want to get his truck fucked up.
So I dunno. You know, I just,
it just fucking annoys me.
That song just annoyed the shit out of me
on both levels where you got somebody,
it's like,
just break up with the guy
and your solution is,
you know something,
if a girl ever fucking cheated on me that,
that I would break up with them.
I'm not saying I wouldn't flip out
and I give him a good fucking trashing
verbally, but I would
never go in like, uh,
what, you know, throw all their clothes
out in the front lawn and Burnham.
You know, why wouldn't I do that?
I don't know. I don't know why.
I think a lot of it has to do,
cause I'd be fucking worried I'd
get arrested for damaging property.
Why do women have an exemption from
damaging property? I don't understand it.
Have a woman sat there
smashing up somebody's car
and broad daylight because the
guy cheated on him. People would
be laughing. I would be laughing.
Everyone. It, we, it's, it's
a comedy. It's just hilarious.
But if the exact same scenario
was going down and a guy did it,
it'd be the classic, you know, the cops
come and they put you in that little,
you get tasered and they mush your face
into the fucking pavement. I Dunno,
I get it. Women have carry a kid around
in that goddamn stomach for nine months,
but I don't think that gives you the right
to go out and tack somebody fee Arrow
. I really don't. You know, so why
don't you guys just fucking relax.
All right. Yeah. A bunch of
Goddamn Psychos, you know,
with your, I'm on my period
excuse, so three weeks a month,
you're out of your fucking mind.
I think if a girl goes,
even if you were cheating on
a girl or on a woman, right?
And she fucks up your car,
I really think you ought to be able to
go up to her and give her a nice fucking
two piece combination to
the Goddamn fucking cabbage.
What do you think about
that? Right? Just fucking,
just hook off on that fucking
hair teased head a lettuce on the
top of her fucking shoulders. Right?
What would you go with?
I'm really gonna alienate a
lot of my thoughts on this one,
and I want you to know that most of this
is not me advocating punching a woman
in the face.
Most of this is,
I can't fucking sit in this
stupid hotel room anymore.
I can't fucking do it.
I've had the Goddamn
okay.
Do not disturb light
on for like four days.
They probably think I overdosed in here.
I'm really big on that.
Don't clean up the
room. Beat it. You know,
you gotta come in and every three days
and change the sheets. Like I'm a royalty.
I changed his sheets like
fucking once every three weeks.
Maybe that's the only if that's only
if they are white and I could tell how
filthy they are. That's right. Wrinkle
your nose up. You fucking pop his broads.
That's how I live my life. Um,
Jesus, why am I attacking women?
I don't know why. What was I
talking about? Oh yeah. If you,
if you could punch a woman in a face,
you're allowed to punches,
what would you go with?
Okay. What'd you go? Classic.
Would you set up the
overhand right with the jab?
Would you actually waste the
jet? You know, waste a jab?
Would you go, this is just
evil. All right, I gotta get
off this fucking subject.
I know that song just annoyed me.
Um,
I hate those fucking songs when women
just just openly talk about how they're
going to go out and destroy a guy's
fucking property rather than break up with
them, you know? And it's considered
some sort of justification,
you know, rather than looking
inward going, you know,
maybe I'm a bad judge of character.
What sort of qualities am
I looking for in somebody?
And I'll date that.
I mean,
didn't the fact that the guy had a
souped up four wheel drive truck,
didn't that give it all up within that?
Give it away on any fucking level.
Huh? In his, I mean, souped up four
wheel drive truck, Carrie Underwood,
your dumb fucking, what
else did he have? Huh?
A a fucking earring hanging down with
a lightening bolt on the side of it.
I have this fucking song sticks.
This is one of the,
you know why I hate to sign this and
I'm going to do my whole podcast on this
fucking song. This is going to
be one of those fucking songs.
When I'm the raw on the
road and I'm hating my life,
you and I just don't want to go back
to the hotel room and be lonely and I'm
going to go out to a bar and that
song's going to come on and fucking four
fucking twats with their ear piercing.
I'm singing and I'm drunk.
High pitch voices are going to start
singing every fucking word of that song.
Liked it. They liked these
fucking cunt bad asses. Okay.
Okay. And I'm done.
Alright, I'm done with that.
I'm done with that fucking Oh
Jesus Christ. That fucking suck.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
hey,
what's going on?
It is Bill Burger and this is the
Monday morning podcast for Monday.
Uh, what does it March 1st, 2009. Ah,
in like a lamb out like a lion.
I ate all that old fucking crap.
They always talk about, you know,
I've got to look at some
fucking groundhog in the,
what are they going to let that shit go?
You know? Yeah. I've done mall shows.
It's fucking left ball. Then it's
gonna rain for the next nine Dars Jag.
Hey nobody's, he's to dress up in a
top hat like it's the fucking old days.
You know what I mean?
Some people are just so fucking married.
It's disgusting that
they, they, they just,
that's all just repressed
like sexual energy. You know,
they've been banging this same broad
until their fucking uterus dried out.
You know?
So now they got to go out and they got
to dress like fucking JP Morgan waiting
for some wrote in to stick his fucking
head out and then they got, you know,
and if you're not familiar with
the expression, they have a,
what is it in like a lamb out
like a lion and like a lamb out.
Like I don't know what the fuck it
means. You know, if it starts off good,
it's going to end bad.
If it starts off bad,
it's going to end a good,
that's how that would go.
I am completely not even fucking
prepared for this podcast.
Usually I wait until about 45 minutes
in and I let you guys figure it out that
the podcast is going
to suck for this week.
But I'm going to give you a warning almost
like have you ever see like going to
movies coming out and they say a,
this film has yet to be rated.
That means usually that
means it sucks so bad.
We're trying to keep it
away from the critics.
So by the time you figure out it's sucks,
you're going to be looking
at your date like, Oh God,
you know what, I saw trailer,
we all going to be bad. Will
Smith is in it. You know,
he's playing some homeless guys
that even in the world. Um, yeah,
this podcast is gonna suck.
Um, I just got back from, uh,
I was in, uh, Houston, Texas and uh,
I was so good in Texas and
I don't mean comedically.
I mean as a person that I'm,
I was just mind numbingly boring fucking,
you know,
I'm not drinking no internet porn.
You can't do it. It's impossible. No,
there's never an expression out there
that says beware of the man that has no
vice, isn't there? Hmm.
Can I just ask you that?
Can I just fucking throw that out there?
You know what?
This is why this sucks right now cause
I'm actually fucking trying to pull
something up right now that I have to
play because yesterday was probably the
biggest fucking hockey game
in the United States. Um,
yeah, probably since, uh, 1980.
That's what they're saying.
I don't want to use that hack thing,
dude, I don't want to do that.
But it was fucking huge.
Evidently 75% of Canada,
they were estimating was watching the
gold medal game and for all you Americans,
actually not Americans, all you, all
you people from the United States, uh,
the u s has a hockey team,
I'll call team USA and every four
years they play in the Olympics and a,
we made it to the final round for the
gold medal and that game was yesterday.
I know it's a little obnoxious,
but that's how I felt in Houston.
If 75% of the people who
are watching it in Canada,
I don't think there was more than 75
people watching it in fucking Houston.
They just completely didn't give a shit.
I went down, this is basic, basically,
I don't want to ruin it for
you, but a Canada one, um,
they just played a better game. I think
that they, they were a better team. Uh,
yesterday, I don't know what they
did. Figured out their lines,
but it was night and day since we, uh,
beat them the week before how they looked,
they looked awesome. I definitely
thought they were a better team.
And what I liked was nobody really choked.
There wasn't any bullshit fucking
calls. Um, I'll fuck you Canada.
What the offsite thing. You guys got
enough penalty. Shut the fuck up.
I want to hear it. You won the game. Um,
but that play was off sides
and we did get a goal,
but you know what I'm saying.
But it was pretty much, it was,
it was free of that and it
went into overtime. And uh,
I so wanted the United
States to win because, uh,
obviously I'm a huge, it was on two
levels. Obviously I'm a huge hockey fan,
but then secondly,
the level with which Canada gives a shit,
it is very few times that
you get a chance to devastate an entire
nation and it doesn't involve dropping
bombs on them. You know, like
if we want that hockey game, um,
I don't know what they
would've been doing.
Those people would have been slitting
their wrists up there and their rig loose.
Sorry, I just had to throw some
ignorant American shit out there.
Like you guys are fucking smart
up there smoking cigarettes,
sitting in a fucking Tim Hortons eating
another fucking donut. What you think?
I never been to Calgary.
You know think you never thought I took
that fucking highway up to Edmonton.
Pass all those fucking
cows in the oil wells.
Fucking guys. Everybody's acting
like their cosmopolitan. All worldly.
Even these days,
I'm getting tired of it.
I'm tired of listening to the fucking
hype about how fucking stupid Americans
are. People who misstates here,
not North Americans in general.
Just people from the fucking states.
And then you travel and you run into the
exact same shithead that you are with a
different accent. All right? Get over
your fucking cells. But you know,
I got to give it up.
Got to give it up. Uh,
they won the fucking game.
So I figured I'd find the gayest
version.
That national anthem.
True.
I think this was a, I don't know if this
was old town or if this was in sync.
Who did this one? This is a tribute
to Canada. Our friends up north
never harmed a fly.
Never started a war.
Like to pretend you're from Paris.
Alright. Stop blaming the east.
That arrogance goes right across the
country. Stop with the arm down to Earth.
Cause I'm from Winnipeg. I'm not buying
it all you guys. You look down on us.
Okay. I can't even listen to the
rest. I gotta I gotta leave it.
You won the fucking gold medal.
Go ahead.
I bet you guys a tearing up
up there right now. Aren't you
crying into your fucking, I don't
know what, some sort of winter garb.
Oh,
is there any worse than acapella singing?
What is the worst mimes or
Acapella? I think. I think
Acappella Leisha can't hear him or
him. What's the deal? Yeah. Right.
Sons of bitches you want again,
but by the skinny teeth.
Congratulations.
Your fucks.
It's a hell of a game. Does a hell of a
Goddamn game. You know, the best part was,
was, uh, the United States.
For those of you in America who
didn't fucking watch it, uh,
Zack per se, or the fuck you
say his last name is, he, uh,
he fucking tied it up with 20 seconds
left and 75% of Canada collectively shit
their pants. And I was like, oh my God,
it's going to happen now that they
soiled themselves. Ah, you know,
they just fucking annoy me.
They're cocky fans annoy
me every fucking it
would come down. Right. Anytime
you Americans doing anything good,
they'd always be that fucking
idiot wrapped in the, the America,
the fucking Canadian flag
gesturing at the fucking ice.
Like the ref miss something.
That's what I don't like about Canadians
when it comes to hockey is their
fucking, you know, this is our game.
Did we get pissed when the Blue
Jays won the fucking world series?
I maybe a little bit. I was a, you know,
I don't know. Fuck, I don't remember.
You know,
I did realize that the fucking Stanley
Cup has not been in Canada since 1993,
you know, so maybe that's why they went
so crazy. Hey, what the fuck did they do?
The metals,
by the way,
I kind of tapped out in the last couple
of Olympics that you still look cool.
It used to look like an Oreo cookie,
but it was made out of gold that had
the same sort of engraving, right.
Had there like the Olympic sign and now
it looks like you took the metal and you
put it on the fucking railroad
tracks. Somebody ran over
it. You know what I mean?
I don't know. Whatever. I'm
fucking around. Congratulations. A,
that was a great game. It was great
for hockey, but it was definitely a,
all you guys out there, listen to me
talk shit, you know, and enjoying, uh,
Peyton Manning, uh, losing the
Superbowl fucking up and all that. Uh,
the Karma came back around.
I was devastated all by
myself out in Houston. And,
uh, but it was, it was still
great, man. And, you know, I,
I did make fun of Michael will
bond saying when he said, ah,
this is the best hockey out there.
I gotta admit,
I gotta admit without the A,
without the fighting.
Um, the, uh, I don't know. Do you guys
like no touch icing, automatic icing?
I liked a lot of it.
I got to admit,
I kind of liked the PG version of hockey.
It was kind of Nice. This is sacrilegious
to be saying this, but I kind of,
I kind of enjoyed it,
you know, to be great.
If a couple of goons would make it
to the fucking, the Olympic squad,
you just so good. They put you on
there. You just have like, you know,
George La rock verse. Uh, I dunno
who's the other big heavyweight,
that fucking who's at big going on,
on uh,
Minnesota with that weird last name that
has like three letter bs and an n in it
or some shit. I don't fucking
know. Anyways, let's plow
ahead with the podcast.
This is the Monday morning podcast
from Monday, March 1st. Uh,
the rent is due and, um, yeah,
I had a hell of a fucking weekend
out there in Houston, Texas.
I want to thank everybody who
came out to the Improv. And, um,
I had great shows Friday night that led
into Saturday night and Saturday night.
I think I might've had two of the best
shows I've had in recent memory. Um,
they were just, uh, everything
sort of clicked. I kind of,
I was sitting in this
restaurant, um, eh, this is,
this is how clean living I am.
Okay.
It's right before 7:00 AM I have an a
salad with fucking a chicken breast in it.
Right? I got my laptop, I'm typing out
this fucking script, finishing it up,
drinking a glass of water,
getting the shit out of the way.
And I just remember like,
just having this feeling like this,
this is what Tony Robbins does,
you know?
And that's how he has that fucking psycho,
terminally happy fucking smile
on his face, you know? And um,
I don't know. I realized some shit in
that moment. I brought it to stage.
I started riffing. The whole fucking
thing worked. And I recorded it. But
the beautiful thing about the universe
is when you hit something great happens,
something else has to balance it out.
Like I get to see Peyton manning fuck
up the Superbowl and thus make me feel
vindicated.
And then two weeks later,
a crushing fucking over time loss.
It wasn't crushing cause they used,
they used to beat us by fucking,
they used to be this like seven to one.
All right, you gotta admit.
Okay, you can at a Fox.
Remember that back in the day it was a
joke. Our hockey was a joke. First of all,
90% of the people in the
league were all from Canada.
Granted they were only six
fucking teams, but still, um,
and you guys used to crush us and now
we're breathing down your neck and you
better enjoy that gold medal cause I
got a feeling that's the last one you're
going to be fucking having for
awhile. How are you like dad? Huh?
Now you wait till fucking next year buddy.
Ah,
can you guys handle that shit
talking? All right. Anyways,
so twice this weekend I had
incidents with people in the crowd.
Um, and both of them were women. And A,
I'm the first to tell you that I do have
fucking issues with women, but the, uh,
the first night, um, I was on stage
and there was this woman write down,
I don't know if it's stage left to
stage right from where I'm fucking at it
stage left.
All right?
So I think that's the proper terminology.
Why the fuck do you guys need
to know stage left stage, right?
You're in the crowd. You
know, I go down to midas.
Do I need to know what fucking wrench
they're gonna use? I don't need, okay,
so stage left or right, I'm looking
down and a, this fucking girl is, she's,
you know, she's talking,
continue on with my jokes.
They look down and she's still talking.
So finally I say, hey, it is sweet tits.
Why don't you a, what's the
problem? What are you talking about?
And then she does the usual [inaudible],
you know,
I wouldn't say she was attractive
if she was in from a small town.
She be a Hottie, you know, just
out of percentages. But um,
so she did the usual like,
what, what? I have a,
I had no idea what the fuck I'm doing.
You know, 10 minutes later I look back,
she's still fucking talking.
It gets a little more heated.
I basically went to her table about six
times until I finally told her to shut
the fuck up and then I don't really even
fuck her. Remember? Then all of a sudden,
next thing you know,
she's hammered and she's getting kicked
out when I got like five minutes left in
my show, so she threatened to sue
the place and all this type of shit.
Now usually that's the end of the night,
you know,
the whole crowd is fucking clapping as
she's leaving because she's been fucking
annoying. Everybody around
them who paid to see the show.
All right, so usually that's the end of
it. But you know what this psycho did.
She actually sent a letter to the Improv
and she tried to pretend that she,
that she wasn't herself.
She tried to pretend that she was an
impartial member of the audience who
completely agreed with her and thought
that I was a fucking idiot. So, uh,
I want to read you a little bit
of this fucking letter here. Um,
to whom it may concern, I attended bill
burrs first show on Friday, the, uh,
the 26th and was utterly
appalled by his performance.
I love comedy. Oh, this is what you
always have to do whenever you bitch. Um,
and you're not there in person so they
can't see what a radiant human being you
are. You have to then
after you state your bitch,
you then have to fucking
show how easygoing you are
as a human being. So anyway,
she saw my show. She was utterly appalled
by, by my performance. And then she goes,
I love comedy and I certainly
expect there to be rudeness,
crudity and what can be offensive topics.
That's what comedy is all about. It
makes it fun. That being said, okay,
now she's established how fucking cool
and laid back she is back to trash and oh
, fucking howdy duty. Here
she goes. That being said,
Bill Bird took it way too far and he was
quite unprofessional to say the least.
While initially there was indeed
quite a lot to laugh at. Yeah.
That was the part where you was sober,
your fucking lightweight.
That was the beginning of the show when
you weren't fucking on your nine fucking
drink and you are actually paying
attention to the show. So yeah,
initially there was indeed quite
a lot to laugh at. I ain't,
this person's trying to write as if
it's medieval times and I should be like
fucking holding this thing like a goddamn
scroll. I know that isn't medieval ish,
but she's used,
she's doing that biblical thing where
she's using extra fucking words to try to
sound intelligent.
Well,
initially there was indeed quite a
lot to laugh at instead of being,
at first it was funny. Um,
anyways, the show ended up,
the show ended up being a complete
disappointment okay for it. Okay.
This is her complaint here for at
least 30 minutes. He, blasphemy,
God and the name of Jesus Christ.
He outright degraded the
Catholic religion. All right.
Now that's complete bullshit.
I only blasphemy God,
the name of Jesus Christ and the Catholic
religion for about seven minutes.
30 minutes. What, what am
I fucking George Carlin,
I can't talk about
anything but 30 minutes.
Maybe you weren't so fucking
hammered. You'd dumped cunt. You know,
you'd have a better perception of,
of, of how much time in a lapsed.
Oh Jesus. All right, let's
continue. Although I'll go,
that's this and another thing,
another thing w was she,
she's pulling this move again. He
outright degraded the Catholic religion,
although I do not belong to this religion.
So now you're supposed to be like,
wow,
she's not even part of that religion.
And even she found it offensive.
Have you guys picked up on that?
On Youtube at all? Like when
someone wants to trash Obama, um,
they'll say like Obama is
the worst president ever.
And then the right and I'm a democrat. You
know, like you can prove it either way.
Just trying to cut people off the past
before they go, fuck you, you Fox News,
watching right-wing, whatever. You know,
women need to shut the fuck up. And
I'm a girl, that dumb shits. Okay.
So evidently she was,
she was offended and she's not even a,
she's not even Catholic anyway.
She said it was offensive and
what he said went on and on again,
while this type of thing should be accept
a expected, he took it way too far.
Um,
and there was a young lady who like I
and my friends was becoming offended.
Yeah, of course she was because
she's you, you fucking psycho.
Can you believe that she
thinks I'm this fucking stupid.
And I know at this point is
probably not obvious to you guys,
but wait till I finish the rest of this.
All right.
I'm probably going to sound like some
maniac here, but I don't give a fuck.
I said there was a young lady who like
I and my friends was becoming offended
and said a few words instead of
few words to someone at our table,
you fucking lion sack a Twat. Anyways, uh,
she, he said when he rudely addressed
her, that's when I said, Hey lady,
I guess lady is rude.
Hey Lady,
could you do me a favor and maybe
look at the show at some point. Um,
he said when he really addressed her,
she told him that she was Catholic.
That never happened.
He had no apologies or considerations.
Just utter disrespect. Okay? First
of all, she never said that out.
She never said she was Catholic.
And if she did, she said,
it's so quietly that I couldn't hear it.
So how the fuck could this random fucking
woman in the crowd hear what she said?
Oh, this fucking thing. It's gonna make
me mad again. Alright, let's continue.
After he finally got off that subject,
his show just got worse.
This is when she's on
about her sixth strength.
It appeared to my friends and I that he
may have been getting heat from some of
the audience and that
he felt uncomfortable.
This may very well be the reason why
he continued to pick on the lady,
the lady. This is why I'm picking
on her, not because she, I,
and as I'm doing my act,
by the way,
I keep looking down and she's getting
some sort of Martini thing that looks like
there's a beer in it.
I don't know what the fuck it was.
It's one of those chick fucking drinks,
you know,
like what if we take rid pair and
second fucking roofie in it? You know,
she was drinking those
things. Okay. And uh,
so now she goes in this
very male, uh, he goes,
this may very well be the reason why he
continued to pick on that lady even at
one point telling her to shut the fuck up.
Yeah.
I told you to shut the fuck up because
you were talking the entire time you Twat
anyways. A, this is
downright unprofessional.
Who said that someone cannot say a
few words to people at their table.
Did you see how obvious this is that
this is this the actual fucking woman who
would give a fuck this much?
That you would write three pages.
They were quietly speaking and not
making any noise whatsoever. Oh,
yet you heard her say that she was
Catholic on the other side of the stage.
There was another table,
uh,
talking quite a bit more and they were
louder due to the drinks yet he did not
pick on them. Do you want to fucking all,
let me just fucking relax here.
This isn't even funny anymore.
Like I totally lost. I have, I've
lost the whole humor in this.
This is fucking making me so mad.
They were more disruptive than anything,
although he of course made jokes about it.
All right?
There was this table next to me.
They were also drinking,
but they were more doing that church thing
where I would say something funny and
then they was sorta like fucking repeating
it so they were a little bit rowdy,
but they were acceptable.
This woman who was fucking out drinking
everyone at the other table had
basically essentially her fucking back
to me to the point that if I fucking
punched her in the back of the head, I
would've got two minutes for boarding pat.
Possibly a fucking game is conduct.
All right. There is something for you.
Olympic hockey, fucking people. Anyways,
let's, let's continue here. Actually,
that would be roughing,
wouldn't it?
Let's say I took the mic stand
and I turned it sideways.
I could have crosschecked her on the
fucking neck. All right, here we go.
We are convinced that his wrong
demeanor was due to his discomfort.
After realizing that he had offended
some of the audience in order to justify
himself and ease any tension
coming from the audience member,
he said something along the lines of,
don't listen to me.
I'm just an idiot up here speaking.
Pray for me please.
That was obviously a demonstration
of his uneasiness that this is,
this is how drunk she was.
What I was doing was I was,
I was telling people in the crowd that
if they were religious that I respected
their religion. All right? I just ha,
I just personally don't buy into it.
Okay,
so I'm only stopping right now to
say this because I know some of you,
you get so religious,
you get so into it that you can add.
You get so holy that you
can actually commit murder.
You know God's usually Angela
tool or you know, vengeance.
I think that was the line I used. I said,
okay, you shouldn't be getting mad at me.
You should pray for me
to help me see the light.
And everyone got a huge fucking
laugh at it. About it. Okay.
And this lady is basically us. She's,
I can't wait to email her back.
I don't know. I, I've, I've flipped
flopped a hundred times in my head.
What I was going to say, you
know, I just can't wait to, uh,
I think I'm just gonna write back
something really quickly. Like, Ruth,
you actually pretending to not be the
dumb drunk bitch in the crowd is one of
the funniest things I've ever read.
Something to that effect.
Basically let her know that I know that
it's her and I'll see you next year at
the Improv. You're content. Um,
anyways, I'm very surprised.
Surprised that your calling,
this is where she tries to, um,
this is where she tries to
get me banned from the club.
I'm very surprised that a,
your club hosted this comedian.
It was a true disappointment.
I am embarrassed as I was the one who
suggested the Improv when my friends and I
were planning to on sing a comedy show.
I do hope that you will consider not
having this comedian back as he gives your
club a bad name. If this is a, this
had been my first time to the Improv,
I never would have returned. You might
consider hiring some local talent.
There are several good
comedians in the area.
We are good friends with one of them.
If you'd like his name,
I'll be happy to give it to [inaudible].
All right.
As for the lady who we picked on,
she and her table were
unjustifiably asked to leave.
There was no grounds on having them
escorted from the show right in the middle
of it.
That's how drunk she was.
She got escorted out 50 minutes
into my one hour set and she's like,
she was escorted out in the middle of it.
Do you understand how drunk
this woman was? I talked for,
Jeez about Jesus for 30 minutes.
No, actually it was seven minutes.
I was escorted out in the middle.
No,
you actually escorted out 50 minutes into
the show when you were on your fucking
six drink.
You're drunk count.
There were no grounds of on
having them escorted from, uh,
from the show right in the middle of it.
Again,
they were not being disrupted at all.
This and this,
this impartial person just wants to keep
talking about how innocent this fucking
lady is that she never met. If it hadn't
been for bill burr picking on them,
no one would even notice them. Okay.
The kids who tell this is just the,
the fucking drunk argument they had in
the crowd and in the car on the ride home,
the loud table.
And the other side though is the one
that took away attention from his show.
I do understand that it is private
property and then anyone can be asked to
leave at any time. But this was wrong
to do. This is a wrong time to do it.
I personally believe that she should
receive an apology from the Improv,
but mostly from bill burr. That's
clearly not my call. Just the thought.
What a fucking,
ah,
okay.
I don't know. Did I take too long
reading that fucking thing. There you go.
You want to be a standup comedian? That's
what the fuck you have to deal with.
She's actually like a total
fucking control freak.
And what happened that night was
she completely lost on all levels.
Okay.
You know,
it's weird.
You become like a part time psychologist
as you're breaking down the crowd as a
comedian and she sat at the
power position at the table.
The table is at like a fucking,
we'll say like a 30 degree
angle coming in stage left.
This is going to get technical. All
right, you fucked. Don't, don't,
don't leave me here. She, you know,
she didn't sit at like the the chair
furthest away. If you sit furthest away,
everybody you're at the table with
has the back of their head to you.
So then when you want to fucking
talk, it's, it's a difficult time.
What she did was not only did
she sit in the first chair,
she sat on the first chair closest to me,
so they'll,
so all she had to do is turn around.
She had the whole fucking tables
attention and when she stood up,
when she went to leave her whole table
stood up like a bunch of fucking minions.
You know,
like you remember that dude,
he used to carry the fucking umbrella
for puffy. That's how they all got up.
It was pathetic.
And people like that surround themselves
with fucking weak people like that
because any normal people, person,
you know, think about that.
All you guys listening right now,
if you're,
if your buddy was being a drunk fucking
asshole and got booted from the club,
would you get up and leave immediately?
Stand up like the fucking general just
got up. I mean, I guess maybe you would.
Could you be walk,
he's drunk.
Maybe he's going to go fuck and walk
out and pee on a cop or something.
I guess maybe. I Dunno. Anyways,
you know, before I email her back,
what do you guys think I should write
back and come up with something clever
other than calling her a con like I did.
I think I'm just,
I'm going to write back something to the
effect that I realized that it was her.
And um, I don't know. I don't fucking
know. Was that just a big waste of time?
Should I not have been bothered
with all of that? You know,
I dunno. Then I had another incident with
another fucking person. I don't know. I,
I have issues with, with a
beautiful woman. I really do.
This is actually a bit I want
to do on stage and I'll just,
I'll maybe I'll do part of it for you
here at bay. The basic idea, I just,
I don't respect them on a certain level.
I feel like I had to do something
to achieve in life. All they had to do
was basically they were born beautiful.
This, it's really not an accomplishment
I guess. You go to the gym,
you stay beautiful past a certain age.
It is an accomplishment I guess.
But you know,
I don't know,
for in order as a guy to
get around beautiful women,
you have to accomplish all this shit in
life and all they have to do to get to
where the fuck you're at
after accomplishing all this
shit is basically take a
shower and feather their hair back
like Farrah Fawcett and they're in the
fucking VIP. You know? I also
don't like them because, uh,
I dunno. I Dunno if they're
smart. They, if they're smart,
they're absolutely stunning though.
I have to admit that. But you know,
okay.
If they're, if they're dumb, that's like,
it's like you got a Lamborghini but you
find out it has a four cylinder in it,
or even worse. My fucking hybrid. Did
that make any fucking sense? You know,
they have that one default emotion.
Oh my God.
And they give 58 different reads.
You know,
if they see something cute like a
little puppy, they're like, oh, Mike,
good.
You know, if you do something
sweet from, Oh my God,
yeah.
Did you know you'd do something
that they fucking hate? Oh my God.
Fucking idiots. They got
three words floating around
in there and they're in VIP,
you know? Yes. Slapped a fucking
spit out of the mouth. All right,
let's plow ahead here. This is the Monday
morning podcast and I'll also, you know,
I don't know why I didn't think to say
this. I'm like, oh, I have a new player.
I've kind of abandoned Libsyn already.
Okay.
That was like my rebound girl after
I broke up with fucking Geniecast.
It just didn't work out. Um, you know,
like Eddie Murphy and one of
the spice girls, you know,
but fortunately I didn't impregnate a
luminosity that luminosity. I'm sorry,
I've just redone that. Ah,
Lipson, I'm speaking of that.
I'll let the cat out of the bag. Um,
this is something I'm trying to do is uh,
to actually go on the internet
and rather than becoming,
even even dumber than I really am or
is it more dumb? I don't even know.
I know it's more stupid. It's not
stupid or is it? I have no fucking idea,
but all I know is,
uh,
I'm trying to figure out how not to become
more of a shithead online and I would
really like to start this
as a new segment. Where is,
are there things out
there that I can look at?
I know ted.com I love that site even
though I haven't been to it in a month.
Ted like Ted kennedy.com
minus the rape and alcohol.
Um, there's one out here
called luminosity.com,
l u m o s I t y.com.
And it's basically games for your
brain. And I'm telling you, man,
it's fucking awesome and I cannot even
begin to tell you how low I scored on
these things. Uh, you know, they got
these things, they got everything.
Literally they got one game
called like duck hunting, right?
And what happens is a duck appears
on the screen while simultaneously,
you know, somewhere in your
peripheral vision, while
simultaneously on the screen,
a letter appears.
And then what you have to do is you have
to click where the bird was and also
remember the letter. And then when
the, then they'll give you a series,
like a lineup, usual suspect of letters.
You got to pick the right letter.
And then it's like wheel of fortune.
You got one letter and you're trying to
solve the word and it's a name of a bird.
So you're fucking learning to look
at two things at one time, process,
both of them. And you're getting better
at wheel of fortune all at the same time.
And learning new names of fucking birds
that you didn't even know existed.
That's just one fucking game.
Okay?
So if we can get back into the
ying and Yang, the balance of life,
if you want to somehow balance off nine
hours of fucking going onto you porn and
watching people get kicked in
the nuts on youtube, I highly,
I can't recommend this site highly enough.
You can sign up,
you get a free week of games,
luminosity.com l u m o s,
I t y.com and then, you know, even
the membership is not that bad.
But, um, I dunno, I'm not the brightest
guy, but I think I have good common sense.
And I have a feeling then in about 10
years after all the how to get fucking a
six pack abs books have been written,
somebody is finally going to focus on
the brain and start to realize that your
brain, like your fucking midsection
can turn to mush the exact same way.
And like I,
I definitely think my brain is not
nearly as sharp as it was 20 years ago.
It's weird because as you
get, you get older, you know,
that whole thing, you know,
you get older, you get wiser, you know,
basically you're learning from fucking up,
but you're not as sharp.
And, uh, I dunno this, this,
this,
um,
this site was the closest thing to doing
like mental pushups and they're cool.
They're fun games, man.
It taps into the video.
I actually have a new found
respect for video games where like,
um, you know, I,
I got away from video games because they
were just eating up all of my free time.
The last one I really played
was grand theft auto part three,
and it absolutely consumed my life.
And the thing about that game was
even after I finished the game,
I had to get the sheets. I'm going to
lie to you. I'm not gonna lie to you.
You had to cheat, you know, um,
when I finally finished everything,
I would still play the game
and just go on those rampages.
And I found it to be like a stress relief
and uh, but it was just like too much.
But after it, seriously, after playing
those games, I kind of realized that, um,
look at me. I'm too fucking
stupid to convey this idea.
Just go to luminosity.com and if anybody
else knows any other sites like that or
just something that, uh, can
give me some mental setups,
I would really like it because I'm,
I'm getting into that stuff. Like,
I don't know if I told
you guys a this comedian,
I forget who the fuck
it was told me about.
There was some book out
there that was saying, um,
a great exercise to do is if you're like,
lefthanded is to start doing things with
you that you normally do with your left
hand right handed.
All right,
I'm going to wait for you guys to
finish doing the Dick joke there.
[inaudible] fucking rub. One elder
will wait few weeks. Somebody else, uh,
you guys fist pumping in your cubicles
with that hack joke from fucking make me
laugh in 1977.
Can I continue with my podcast?
Thank you. Um, no, it actually,
I don't know what it does. It's,
it's somehow it actually makes you more,
uh,
God, I'm so fucking stupid.
What is the word? Um,
like say if you were playing
guitar, say if you're, uh,
if you're a lefthanded
guitarist like I am,
it's so pathetic to even
call myself a guitar.
Someone who attempts to play guitar.
Um, I play left handed. If you actually,
if I were actually to fuck around on a
right handed guitar and try to learn to
play something,
if I,
then the the second I went
to the lefthanded guitar,
you would actually learn it quicker.
I have no idea why,
which should be obvious at this point
because I could barely fucking explain it.
So anyways, I fly a lot. It
drives me nuts. I hate flying.
And so what I do when I fly is I actually
sit there and I listen to music and I
write the lyrics with my right
hand rather than my left hand.
And I've actually gotten like
halfway decent at it. And uh,
at the very least I'm thinking of someday
if I'm unfortunate enough to have a
stroke, you know, my turnaround
time's going to be incredible.
I'll be rubbing them out.
I'll be right in fucking letters
catching the drool with my opposite hand.
You know, that's so fucking bad. Yeah,
that's what it is. Join me.
Become stroke proof or whatever.
Not stroke proof. Become A, I
dunno, cuts your rehab costs 50%.
God knows nobody has fucking
health insurance anymore.
It could be a good thing.
Right? Have I said anything funny
in the last fucking 19 minutes?
I have no idea.
Somewhere in the middle of that letter I
got fucking mad again and all the funny
went out the window. And I'll tell you
the first rule of fucking losing a crowd.
Well, I guess no confidence and
having no jokes would be first,
but other that it's just going up there
and being an angry fucking cycle. Um, oh,
I want to thank everybody
for, uh, you know,
last week I talked about women's
curling and uh, and by the way,
I totally enjoyed the Olympics.
I love the Winter Olympics and I'm
sick of people shitting on them.
All these late night talk show hosts
talking about how those are the fucking
boring. Really. Why don't you go
do another lame monologue, Huh?
About fucking that girl who got eaten
by a fucking whale. Give me your take.
Coming out there wearing a suit like you
have a fucking war when before you had
the Goddamn show.
Sorry.
You know I get heated when people
make fun of the Olympics. You know,
I was talking about how hot the
fucking women of curling were.
A little bit of phlegm left.
Um,
and somebody said a was
actually saying like,
I was trying to figure out why I was
finding these fucking women so attractive
other than the obvious that they were good
looking women. This guy actually said,
hey, bill, uh, beside the obvious hot
women vigorously scrubbing the floor,
I really set that up bad.
He's saying,
this is why men find women curlers
attractive. I just blew that joke.
He said,
besides the obvious hot women
vigorously scrubbing the floor,
I have two t I you so deserved a huge
laugh on that and I just fucked you out of
it. I'm sorry about that.
Um, anyways, he says,
I have figured out why we
love watching this so much.
When they released that stone,
the way they let it slide out of their
hand is reminiscent of the way a skillful
woman releases your cock after
delivering a massive hand job.
First of all,
I hope you're a surfer because that's
the only reason why to the massive hand
job,
um,
fucking massive hand job. Or maybe
you just have a fucking bit, oh,
maybe I'll just, you have a fat cock.
I Dunno. So anyways, she goes a,
they don't drop it.
Don't push it.
Just let it slide out naturally as I go
to sleep with my boxes around my ankles.
Oh, I forgot. That was
creepy. I know. I read it.
I was supposed to just read the beginning
joke cause I thought the joke was
fucking great.
I forgot the fucking picture in his ugh
guys with those fucking insect looking
legs on guy's legs, like insects
with that fucking hair all over him.
Skinny fucking legs were a mess.
Fucking mess.
I'm like praying mantis legs.
Anyways, I'm a long time ago.
I talked about unacceptable.
This is when,
you know the podcast sucks and I'm just
plowing from fucking topic to topic and
there's just no sort of a no
segway other than dead silence.
Um, let's go to youtube videos for the
week. Let's, let's, let's go over here.
You know, I feel like the
fucking dumb fuck on, uh,
on like jeopardy when there's like
five difficult topics in one easy ones,
you know, great scientist,
architecture, medieval, whatever.
And let's go, let's go with, uh,
developments in lawn chairs for 100.
That's not even easy, isn't
it? I'm so far. I'm just too
dumb. I'm too fucking dumb.
Whatever. You know what? I played those
brain games. I'm too stupid this week.
Here's a youtube video to look up.
Look up Douche off.
D O u c h e o f f a Douche off.
Maybe you'll find that humorous. I
can't remember if I did. I think I did.
I believe I did because I left it
there. Ah, bad wedding stories.
This is another topic. Who the fuck
do I sound like I'm doing right now?
Did somebody do a Bob Dole
impression lay out of, I can't.
Can I tap out at this fucking point
37 minutes in a bag. Wedding stories.
I'm, hey bill, I haven't listened
to your podcast since the beginning.
Decided it was about time I emailed
you and told you how much I enjoy it.
Thank you very much. Uh,
but, but the, the, okay,
let's get to the, uh, to
get to the marriage thing.
Um, okay. I got a marriage
story when I was 23.
I was dating a girl and she got pregnant.
Uh,
dude. Okay. Uh, so we decided
to get married. Okay. Stupid.
Fucking move number two,
even though a month before this I
was thinking about dumping her ass.
Stupid mistake number three. Actually
that was the smart move. That was the,
that was the three card Monte right there.
Don't knock her up.
Don't fucking marry your white.
Knock her up. Marry her dumper ass.
You know which one had the
marble? You fucked up. All right,
so all the plans are made, our families
meet each other. Okay. Just cause I,
you know,
had to do that stupid three card Monte
joke in a desperate attempt to try to be
remotely funny at this
point. You know, it was,
I have a blue wind screen this week.
I'm going to blow that. I'm going to,
I'm going to blame it on that one. You
know, my fucking dog ate the orange one,
so I'm going to blame it on the blue
windscreen. Anyway. So basically,
sky's 23 years old.
He knocks up this fucking girl.
He decides to get married even though he,
he thought about dumping our month before.
So anyway, so all the plans are made.
Um, families meet each other, invitations
are sent out, all that bullshit.
So three days before the wedding,
I'm watching some stupid movie where
this guy tells his other guy that his dad
told him before his wedding,
it's never too late to change your mind,
to which his friend says,
but you're not married.
And I guess it is. That's
a laugh. So anyways, uh,
so taking this as a sign from God that I
just happened to be watching this movie.
I canceled a wedding.
Great fucking move.
Alright. Which says, suffice to say,
brought a shit storm into my life.
The worst part is that
I actually felt so bad.
I married the chick three months
later. Oh Dude, you were out.
You will fucking out.
So basically I was a pussy.
Yeah. Yeah, but too, that's a hard thing.
You were dealing with a lot of shit
at 23 your parents were crying.
She was knocked up. Yeah. I
wouldn't say you were pussy.
You gave into peer pressure.
Anyways,
we were married for seven years with every
year being worse than the year before.
So we're divorced.
So we're divorced now.
So I guess I should have gone
with my gut to wrap this up,
I got a little gripe with,
with chicks.
My ex used to ask me when the marriage
was going down, if I could go back,
would I not meet her? Which
I would say, fuck yeah,
I would avoid you like the
plague. Which she would say, uh,
but w at which point she would say,
but you wouldn't have our two kids,
don't you love them? And then he
would say, yeah, but then I'd say,
but I, I would never have met you,
so I would have never had the kids.
So in that scenario,
the kids aren't even a thought.
This of course would lead to a huge fight
about my lack of carrying a moral to
the story. Don't use logic when
talking to chicks. All right?
That's actually not the moral
to the story. What it is,
is you got to think how women think, you
know, which, you know, if you're lucky,
at some point when you're 90,
you'll know,
you'll understand 10% of what the
fuck is going on in that brain. Um,
basically when she's asking you that,
she was asking that,
I would guess one of two reasons.
One, she was insecure that, you know,
you knocked her up and then you married
her and you know that you were gonna
marry her. Then you broke it off and
then you fucking married her. Uh,
believe it or not, I'm sure that's not
how she dreamed of getting married.
She probably dreamed of
meeting her soulmate and they
were so hopelessly in love
that everyone in the crowd
had tears in their lies for.
They never found a love
soap as great as theirs.
She could have been thinking that and
she wanted you to reassure her or she
probably was just banging you,
you know,
and didn't want to fucking marry you
and didn't think that you were the one
either.
And all of a sudden she got knocked up
and she probably sitting there looking at
the side of your fucking head one
morning as you were eating pancakes,
trying to find where in
the world she loves you.
You know, on what fucking level. You know,
just watching your temples going
in and out as you're chewing,
just fighting that fucking urge to
slam a toaster over your fucking head.
You know, just wondering, how the hell
did I end up with this fucking guy?
Why did I say Yes to this guy?
Why did I let him fucking drop a fucking
load in me? What is wrong with me?
And just trying to make the fact that
you had these two kids justice justice
enough, you know, that's what the
fuck was probably going on. But, uh,
I dunno dude,
you didn't really talk about how much
of a nightmare the wedding was that that
was the meat of the story there.
I think you at the beginning and the end.
But what are you thinking is
she's coming down the aisle.
What is your family thinking?
You're not her up and then you dumped
her and yen and you're like, fuck it,
I'll marry or anyways, and you're only
23 they know you don't want to do it.
Those weren't tears of joy, my friend,
you know? What are you thinking?
Is your up there?
You know,
was your Cumberbun like wringing wet
with flop sweat as you was standing up?
I can't imagine that.
Ugh.
Has anybody ever just ran off the side
door? Cause I could definitely see like,
oh my God, I don't know what to
say. How do I get out of this shit?
And then just in a panic when
they started, Eh, Eh, Eh, Eh,
Eh, Eh, Eh, Eh,
you turn around looking,
where is she a what a fucked and I
have some wedding music underneath this
would've would've been hilarious
if I fucking prepared. You know,
you're looking for the bitch,
where the fuck is you?
And then she comes around the corner
and you're trying to make yourself lover
and she comes around the corner and you
just see that fucking face and you see
those eyebrows and you know,
we're going to be touching by the time
she's 40 and you just fucking run out the
side door in those cheap
tuxedo bowling shoes
and you know what I mean? And you're
in such a fucking panic, you know,
there's no way that you're going to be
able to get your car keys out in time,
get them into the door, open the
door, lock the door and get in there.
And it's like people are going to be
coming out running out of the church like
some fucking Zombie movie as you're
trying to get your car started.
I mean the move there is shit,
if anybody does that,
don't go to your car.
You keep running. Okay.
Most people get married in the suburbs,
so headed head for a wooded area.
Alright, go online. Learn how to turn
your fucking Cumberbun into a tent.
Hang out there for a couple of days.
Let Shit cool off. Grow a beard,
come back to town, get some provisions
that point you'll be so fucking filthy.
You just another homeless guy
wearing a suit. You know what I mean?
Just let her forget all about you.
Then maybe they'll think that you're
mentally ill and then uh, you know,
one day you just show up on your
mother's front steps and she faints.
Her Dad catches you and punches you in
the face cause he's a former marine.
You know, haven't we all seen
this movie? I'm trying to say.
Run out the fucking door.
Run out the fucking door if
you're in that situation,
if you're in that situation.
All right, bill, longtime
listener, first time writer.
I've got a winning story to tell you.
I'm 23 years old now. The 23 year old,
I'd been to a, here's one for you. Don't
go to a wedding or get married at 23.
They all seem to have bad stories.
Um,
I've been to a few weddings and let
me start by saying in this story,
it wasn't actually a wedding I witnessed.
It was a wicking,
a Wiccan hand fastening. Okay. Now though,
for those of you not familiar
with the Wiccan religion,
I just want to state at this
point, neither am I. Um,
I can't remember if that's the one
that actually has all those, uh,
pagans symbols that,
you know,
the Catholic Church then so that they
were devil signs according to the,
uh, fucking Rosetta Stone or whatever that
fucking movie was. I read the book too.
What the fuck is the name of that
Davinci Code? Um, whatever it was called,
a wicked hand.
Fascinating.
And I know that because my sister
didn't invite people to our wedding,
she invited them to her hand fastening.
That's why he knew it was a Wiccan
hand fastening and not a wedding.
Because she said, I'd like to invite
you to my hand fastening cheeses.
Um, he said, if you're 41, you still
don't know what a hand fastening is.
Congratulations. Thank you. Because
I didn't, so anyways, he goes,
I'm 17 at the time,
my sister's 23 or 24,
we both still lived with our parents
who are boyfriend and unemployed,
alcoholic living off money. His
mom left him when she died. Ah,
there you go ladies.
There you go.
You don't have to settle for less when
this guys like him out there. Um, anyways.
Um, fuck am I, why didn't
I make this type bigger?
Jesus. What a flop this
podcast is. So anyways, a,
so this fucking alcoholic was
over for dinner one night.
He tapped his fork on the glass a few
times to get everyone's attention.
We were three feet from him
and immediately my stomach
knotted up because I knew
this moron was about to say something
stupid. You've got to meet you.
You guys are fucking funny writers,
man. Some really talented people.
Listen to this fucking podcast. You
guys write better than I do. Anyways,
basically he announced his engagement
to my sister in front of my mom and dad
pulled out two onyx rings and they put
them on each other's middle fingers.
You know, I went to the Onyx Strip club
in Houston last night. How funny is that?
Anyways,
it was dead silent and um,
the look of re a repressed horror
on my mom's face was unmistakable.
It was so awkward.
So I just started clapping going Yay.
Quietly because nobody else joined in.
Oh, that's great. Is that your
role in the family? You're,
the person always tries to make it
better. Uh, God bless you. Anyways,
it was just dead silence and my sister
and her boyfriend kissing each other like
everything was fine.
A few months later I found out they were
financing those rings and going into
payments on them.
Every week.
My sister's collecting child support and
neither of them have a job and they are
financing onyx hand fastening rinks.
Jesus Christ,
Jesus Christ.
I can't believe there's more to
this story. All right, here we go.
Fucking knee deep. I got to go the rest of
the way. All right. Anyway, so I finally,
uh, it finally to their
hand, fascinating day,
and they're doing the ceremony
right on Newport beach.
It's in the middle of the day on a, on
Sunday in the summer, they didn't have,
oh, they didn't reserve a piece of beach
or anything. They just showed up and go,
hey, let's have the wedding here. Um,
the family we had, I don't know. Fuck,
I gotta sit close to the damn screen.
I can't read anymore. The family we have
near the beach mostly all showed up.
All the people who live near
the beach mostly showed all up.
There were about 30 or 40 of us.
None of us,
none of us are dressed in beach clothes.
Half of them are in suits and dresses.
There are no chairs.
There's not even an altar.
Everybody's just standing around hot and
they can't sit down because there's no
chairs and they don't,
they don't want to ruin their clothes.
My sister shows up in an
all black gown with a veil.
The boyfriend is wearing like a Tux
with his face painted like one of the
misfits, kind of like a
skeleton face. Jesus Christ.
It sounds like the episode of the office.
Anyways,
they don't do any
traditional wedding stuff.
They just go right up front of the crowd
with their Wiccan priest or whatever.
The wicked priest is basically
just a friend of theirs.
He reads a bunch of a bunch of stuff
from a book in some other language.
My sister and the boyfriend are
responding in some other language.
Nobody has any idea what's going on.
Then all of a sudden,
the boyfriend pulls out this
crazy looking knife with a what?
A hilt. I didn't know what that is.
Uses it to cut my sister's veil.
Then pokes the end of it into
his finger until he's bleeding.
He sticks the knife into the sand and
wraps his bloody hand around my sister's
neck while they kiss.
The stone.
Hippy priest holds up his book and
said something loud in that different
language.
I assume it was her equivalent equivalent
of I now pronounce you husband and
wife.
I'm sure being comedian.
You've heard the sound of 50
people gasping simultaneously.
Family members in suits and dresses
are just walking away at this point.
A lifeguard saw with the boyfriend did
with the knife called the cop and the day
ended prematurely with him getting cuffed
and driven away in a police cruiser.
Jesus Christ. Anyways, thanks for the
podcasts. I really enjoy Jesus Christ.
How about a fucking round of
applause for that story? All right.
I think I have to read up on
the a Wiccan religion. You know,
one thing I did like about that,
I did like the fact that they just showed
up and just decided to have a wedding
and they avoided all those other costs.
Um,
cause I wanted to say halfway through
that, like, you know, they didn't have,
they didn't reserve that piece
of the beach or anything.
And I was thinking like,
well, you never had to back in
the day. You know what I mean?
You just fucking had a wedding.
There was,
it wasn't like nine zillion fucking
dollars. Didn't matter where you were,
but I guess you have to do that now.
Uh,
because there's nine zillion
people and uh, and bankers run
the fucking world. Hey,
speaking of that, did you,
somebody sent me an email the other day.
Evidently Europe elected a president.
You hear that Europe elected a
president, not England, not France,
Europe, the entire continent
now has a fucking president,
has one guy in charge of all of them.
See that just like those three d
TVs that are only a few months away,
that new world daughter is going to
be available right down at the best.
Come and sewed, come and fucking soon.
If you go on and read about the uh,
the bailout, uh, rolling stone
has a great article and a,
usually I try to stay away from their
politics because there's so brutally to
the left. It's fucking
ridiculous. Um, you know,
they never trashed Democrats or
when they do it, so like light hand,
they just doing it just because
they trashed a republican so bad.
They're trying to show that they're fair
and balanced like those other fucking
maniacs. Um, Fox News actually has a
store now when you go through the airport,
which I think is hilarious, they sell
water and that type of shit. So I dunno,
it's going to be with going gonna
be one fucking news channel.
There's going to be one president and
one fucking currency and money and you
better do what they say.
Oh, I ra, that's going to be the
end of it, my friends. Um, anyways,
if you want to check it out, it's the, um,
it's the rolling stone that actually has,
uh,
Eric Clapton and Jeff Beck on the cover.
And if you guys are fans of music,
I guess they're going to be doing a
tour together, which is unbelievable.
They used to be big time rivals back in
the day and now they're fucking in their
sixties. They're like, yeah, let's get
some money for the medication we now need.
And A, I guess they're going to be
doing a tour and a, and with that, um,
I didn't have time, you know, cause I,
I got a couple of weird weeks coming
up guys. I gotta tell you this. Well,
I usually take Sundays off,
so I'm flying home on Sundays and so
then I get a good night's sleep and I can
give you a decent podcast. But, uh,
this week and this upcoming week,
I'm going to be at the Improv in San Jose.
And I am working Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday and Sunday so I won't
be, uh, it is a quick flight.
So the next weeks will be a good podcast,
but that's why this one was so late today.
So I apologize and I didn't get a chance
to recommend any of the music that you
guys have been sending in,
but I'll definitely try to
read it next week. And uh,
I finally have gotten into Pan
Tara to a sick fucking level and,
um, if you get a chance, um,
download a vulgar display of
power or cowboys from hell.
And um, I actually used to play
in this fucking, uh, you know,
garage band and a, my brothers
and some of their other friends,
she used to get into thrash
and I was never into it.
I was more liking to ACDC and John Bonam
and trying to get my bass drum foot is
fast as bottoms, so I never got a
double pedal or any of that shit. Well,
few years ago, I finally got one
and listening to cowboys from hell,
I got to fucking get that
down because, uh, I dunno,
combination of Vinny Paul
and Tim Alexander really
make me want to play double
bass and Alex Van Halen. Those are, uh,
and I'm actually listening
to the lamb of God. Now.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
You guys sent me that old school
fucking hip hop from the late nineties.
I fucking devoured that shit. And then
now I'm going into deep into thrash.
I Dunno. I like all of it. I like
all of it except country music. Oh,
speaking of which,
you seen that stupid song that fucking
woman wrote about being a redneck woman.
How she likes being a redneck
woman. Okay. If you guys,
if you got crushed in this economy,
if you want to get rich quick scheme,
just write an anthem that celebrates
being a complete fucking moron.
And I'm
in,
you basically tell people that under
achieving in life is a good thing and
people will absolutely love it. Like,
just sing those stupid songs where like,
I'd rather have a beer and sit in my own
to where then fucking eat a steak and
visit all the countries because,
well,
it's never going to be better land.
But you can right here with my book
and Banjo in a bear, in a tennis fit.
All right. Something like that.
It has to rhyme, you know,
and then you gotta throw the fucking flag
in there. I'll tell you right now, if,
if, if, if country
musicians ever did stand up,
they would be the fucking worst comedian.
They would be the exact kind of comedian.
I hate the one that panders to the
crowd, which is what, you know,
the ones that fucking sit there
and they look at this guy,
he knows what I'm talking about.
Right. Back me up ladies. You know,
oh look at this crowd.
It could look in crowd and
I give yourselves a round
of applause for coming out
tonight. Gad always love coming out here
is one of my favorite cities. You know,
they say that every town.
So it doesn't fucking mean anything.
That's what country singers alike a
lot of them fucking singing those songs
about supporting the troops. I mean, I
mean, you fucking pussy take a chance.
You know, you run a song support
in the fucking troops, like,
like any critic out there is now
going to say like, well, you know,
it's Kinda hacky chord progressions.
I've heard that before.
They can't because you're insulated by
fucking putting our troops in front of
you. You fucking pussy and bullying.
I locked Bayer and ice cream.
If you don't get the fuck out the country,
well you know I like, I like, I like
beer and ice cream too. You know,
he's got everything in there, but saying
we shouldn't fucking punch babies.
Don't punch babies. Ain't,
don't step on the American flag.
And if you do,
I'm going to punch you in the face.
Everybody. All right. Thanks for
listening to this week. Sorry.
It was so disjointed and fucked up, but
that's what you get when it's free, Huh?
Oh, little Catholic guilt
there. I do it for you.
I did it for
[inaudible].
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].